good evening members and officers of the
council members of the press and the
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council the fire of procedures are
as follows if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate via the stairs
or through security doors to my right or
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
do not use the lists and then assemble
in holy square on the green officers
will assist you and advised when it's
deemed safe to return to the chamber the
Proceedings of this meeting will be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the internet I would advise that if
filming takes place anyone in attendance
in the public various may have their
image captured and I urge anyone to
filming proceedings to avoid filming
members of the public particularly if
there are children present does anyone
that's in tens of film the meeting to
worry about that well there we are thank
you for that then just a comment then
for just a comment then about mobile
phones please ensure their turn to
silent and are not use to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress
agenda item number one then is apologies
for absence we have apology some
counselor Glenn Coleman cook are there
any other apologies thank you to a
counselor conference on Chancellor Gary
human
much agenda item number two then the
minutes of the previous meeting which
was healthier on the first of December
2016 I move that the minutes of that
meeting be approved and signed as a
correct record with the vice chairman
please second second issue the members
agree thank you agenda item number three
it has come to our attention so
therefore it is regret that I announce
that Barry coppock has recently passed
away mr. co-op was a counselor from 1991
to 2003 and was chairman of this council
2002 2003 I'm sure council will join me
in expressing sympathy to mr. Cox family
I would now like to invite all members
to stand for a moment science please in
respect of the late mr. cock-ups cut off
served with the late mr. co-op would
anybody like to mention a few words
right thank you i'll begin with the
counselor matter pastries Thank You
chair I didn't serve with Barry but I've
known him for many many years as an
absolute stalwart of the Labour Party
Barry said to me once that everything he
had gained in public life he gained
through being involved with the trade
union movement and with the Labour Party
he was very proud to say I have done
every job in the Labour Party from
cleaning toilets washing windows I had
been award leader in London he had been
a counselor and when they moved to
thanet he represented newington Ward for
12 years and his wife Jackie who had
represented from Peters moved over to
newington and they formed a couple after
whom I think I'm right in saying but no
doubt someone will correct me they may
be the only pair of councillors who have
a street named after them they have cop
clothes in newington named after and I
know they were immensely proud of that
Barry had been a counselor for newington
as I said and he became a leader of this
council and laterally before he decided
to step down he was chair of the council
and got very involved with community
things he got very involved in education
and vices and head teachers and I was
the one that because i worked in schools
I invited me to come and join them he'd
been battling cancer for a couple of
years but he managed to keep smiling and
until quite recently he was still
helping out the North would buy
elections last year and the newington
by-elections earlier in the year people
who were voting in that ward would have
seen Barry and his wife Jackie telling
when people left the vote he was
extremely proud of what you deceived and
I'm happy to say that he passed away
tuesday morning with his wife and his
two daughters beside him unfortunately
because there's a backlog of cremations
his funeral will not take place for at
least four weeks and I hope members who
served with him or knew him through
politics will be able to attend that
funeral thank you
thank you very much go to John thank you
very much chairman there are a few of us
who of us to serve with Barry I was
elected in 1995 and I was buried being
here for the previous four years so I
knew him in opposition and I knew him
when we took control in 1995 he was the
deputy leader than to Harry Pickering
and then he became the leader and later
on a course chair of the council he
played many important roles of in this
council he was the chair of the
regeneration board and that was a time
when the regeneration board was very
much accountable to elected members and
you know Harry our Barry would make sure
that all members were kept informed of
what was happening he had specific
interests in health and housing and
economic development he was very proud
and anxious to make sure we had all year
round jobs because at that time in the
90s we were still very much seen as
seasonal and varies job very much was to
get work for all year round during his
time we had SRB 5s or e6 European
objective 2 and other fundings and we
were able to get the broadstairs campus
and the innovation center going very
much involved in making sure we had sure
start and you know decent standard in
han council housing good homes for
people he also had a great sense of
humor he never stood up without saying
in a packed meeting about Health's or
whatever my name is Barry Copic and I'm
62 I'm 65 68 72 anytime ever went to a
meeting anywhere age Barry was because
he over the many years of tell us whose
age as he stood up and he would act as
if he was an innocent abroad which he
certainly wasn't he was absolutely on
the ball in everything he did and when
the q eq m was under amazing threat of
closure and we had marches and candlelit
vigils and everything Barry and others
including Richard Nicholson with
officers Brian Lehrer and Brian White
had made sure that this council was the
lead in the campaign to save the qe2 em
I'll never forget that they did that and
Barry and I went job I was a
parliamentary candidate up to the ue q m
they didn't want as photographed in
there because it was a different
political outfit government level and so
we had a ver photos taken outside with
anyone who wants to be with us but Barry
was up
lutely instrumental and even in the last
year I phone that has public health
meetings still doing his bit fighting
for the people of Canada but better
health he had as a fair great sense of
humor and one of the things I found
about him was around he had with private
eye because he was such a strong trade
unionist he was insisting that the
printing place he worked would not print
private eye on their soul the
journalists for union and he supported
in a private I found it in a charity
shop this old private eye and with all
about this man Barry Copic that's really
rushed and had the road with that was
our bury his greatest claim to fame
anyone who's ever been the husband of a
mayor tell you and others will know this
but Barry used to joke about I'm going
home to put my frock on I'm going out as
Marisa Bram escape this evening because
course Jackie was the mayor of ramsgate
he would be very very sadly missed by
all of us because we are a family in our
political parties I think all of you
must be the same as Jenny says the
funeral won't be for a while in fact he
he didn't die from the counter he had
pneumonia and I spoke at length kajaki
this evening and she's bearing up very
well those of you who have great
affection for would like to know that
she's bearing up very well as I have
terrific family terrific daughters but
he was a power in this council he did
amazing work for this community and it's
very good that somewhere was named after
the two [ __ ] we used to fail you'd way
that way their vote their work their way
their votes in newington and even long
after they were no longer the
councillors people used to ask for with
a cop books to come and help them thank
you thank you can see Johnson obviously
a lot of us are relatively new here so
we now have a picture of the men thank
you very much councillor hatin thank you
very much chairman yes I first met ferry
in 91 I don't know whether he was
canceled before 91 that I've so he
achieved the role of being the counselor
Barry wasn't just a Labour councillor he
was a district councillor who performed
quite a lot of work other than political
work I don't know how he fitted in
everything
did because quite frankly you know he
worked 36 hours a day doing things for
the community and the people he
represented not just the people who
websense Allah my bad but the whole of
planet and I quite happy that he became
leader of the Labour group in 99 but
would he was dead 2 leader in 99 and
obviously he did quite a lot of work on
behalf of the community and then as well
and everybody that knew very respected
what he did Jackie his wife was mayor as
has been said and she they both took the
job as what it was a 24-hour job plus
everything else I like add kevin that
they did together and i heard from the
first time from you this evening major
sad loss to not only the community but
to me personally thank you thank you
very much careful abated yeah Thank You
chairman I mean everything's really been
said but I just like to add a few words
and probably goes without saying that
politically we didn't agree on too many
things Barry and I and he was a fierce
opponent English chamber and that was in
the good old days when you really could
like lumps out of each other but but you
could always rely on that once you
walked outside that was put to one side
absolutely completely and what I would
just like to say he was an absolute
first champion persona and really does
deserve the respect of everybody you
know that was written at a time as
followed since thank you thank you very
much Clara Tomlinson please Thank You
chair again much has been said which
brings back to mine I first got to know
Barry way back in nineteen ninety-five
at a meeting at the Old Town Hall here
in Margeson it's regarding the Turner
when things started going there but I
got to know him and his Jackie his wife
fairly well with various organizations
and what I was involved in and also and
most people here know I have been
privileged to be the mayor of our town
here and it was an occasion and this is
how I remembered him and I've only heard
about this units ago from cancer Johnson
he's passed away but we went to a
function for the mayor of ramsgate which
was counselor Steve Ward at the time
Albion house where we all have to dress
up as known that may sound a bit funny
coming from me but I'm coming home
yourself tonight and I can see Barry and
Jackie done up and he wasn't very big
anyway jackie was there and if you can
picture gnomes jumping over fences is
something I will never forget lovely
person and it's come as a shock to
myself as well tonight and thinking
chair Thank You Kenneth Saunders please
thank you well we've all heard this
evening Barry the politician obviously
my politics differed with ballot Barry
but we had probably kept it quiet
because we had long conversations are on
a certain subject and he like myself was
a lifelong supporter of a certain
football team from South London the ones
that play in red and white so you can
imagine that we put our political word
differences decide and had some very
long conversations about the days when
footballers again like councillor david
has said footballers were allowed to
kick what's its out of one another back
in the good old days of leather
footballs bought boots and Liverpool's
so lovely character and both councillor
maven myself shared a lot of interest
with Barry and his life with regards to
the twinning association he was very
active in the ramsgate twinning
association and we've been active in the
brawl stairs association so lovely man a
near neighbour of mine and a sad loss
Thank You chairman
thank you very much for those attributes
to very cop up if you'd be so kind as
soon as you know when the funeral is if
you could let me know I will endeavor to
attend a sermon to represent the council
thank you for all those warm memories of
him agenda item number for their
declaration of interests are there any
declarations of interest professor
Campbell we are going to discuss later
all the members allowed from we over
generous allowance my mr. now sleaze
Thank You chairman yes all members have
a general dispensation to discuss
members allowances mid-year treasure
even from fort then agenda item number
five for 2016-17 I call upon Council of
town entry Thank You chair this report
is required in accordance with the cipfa
code of practice on treasury management
during the first half of 2016-17 the
council complied with the requirements
of its annual investment strategy or
rowing was only undertaken for a capital
purpose and the statutory borrowing
limit the authorized limit was not
breached the period continued to be
challenging investment environment with
low investment returns this report was
considered by the government's and Audit
Committee on the 7th of december 2016
and cabinet on the seventeenth of
january i move that council approves the
recommendations thank you is there a
second to please Thank You councillor
fabros members with Thank You chairman I
just wanted to repeat the appreciative
comments that I made it's a cabinet a
while ago I think people thought I was
joking waiting for the punch line but
actually obviously in deadly serious we
have this highly technical and
detailed report prepares to members and
to just nod it through without coming
doesn't do justice to the treasury
management see the tiling finances are
stretched the professionalism out of our
treasury management theme is never more
needed cdc treasury management it is
obviously to the sit for accountant
dakota practice uses in-house expertise
with expert advice and guidance from
capita and a detailed reading of the
report which I'm sure we've all done
shows that every area of treasury
management is covered every risk
assessed all the investment accounts
managed and regularly the terms of every
loan reviewed so I think that you know
we should feel very pleased that we've
got such a good Treasury mention team
and i'll happily support the approval of
this report Thank You chairman thank you
very much to members agree up may I just
thank you on behalf of the team for your
kind remarks thank you very much do
members agree thank you
gender item number six the treasury
management strategy for 2017-18 and I
was advised members in the cordons of
council Procedure rule 17 dot six I will
call for a recorded vote on the motion
or any amendments or substantive motions
I call once more on counselor town in
peace thank you Jeff this report is
required in accordance with the cipfa
code of practice on treasury management
it covers the council's capital plans
treasury management strategy treasury
indicators Prudential indicators and
limits for the 2017-18 to 2019-20
inclusive and the minimum revenue
provision policy and investment strategy
to 2017 18 this report was considered by
the government's and Audit Committee on
the 7th of december 2016 and cabinet on
the seventeenth of january i move the
council approves the recommendations
Thank You counsel town is so second to
please second of cherries live boys
Thank You counsel well
would you like to ditto also counselor
thousand council Gregory's words of
appreciation for the financial strategy
team and the good work that this so
thank you very much gasps oh wellz try
to say that officers this how is
grateful I no need to instruct the
monitor officer to conduct the recorded
vote Thank You German counselor Ashby
Gaza Bainbridge kinds of a food counter
braidwood counselor brim casa Buckley
Catholic Campbell counselor Keith
Coleman cook Catholic collar counselor
crow Brown count saccharine counselor
Dawson Council a day councillors Ella
counselor Dennis Council Dexter cancer
Dixon counselor Edwards counselor
Eleanor counselor Evans counselor Jeremy
fairbrass council in fairbrass casa
Falcon counselor Fenner Cutler game
counselor Ian Gregory councilor Ken
Gregory causa grove casa hatin counselor
House Counsel Jay Jones cancer Johnston
Council Larkins counselor Martin
counselor matter face counselor Parsons
counselor partington counselor Linda
Piper Council Reverend Reverend Stewart
piper three counselor Roy pots council
Linda pops
council Rogers counselor ozeki
councillor david saunders counselor may
you Saunders Castle Savage councillor
shankh castle summer smut Singh count to
a tailor counselor taylor smith cancer
Tomlinson counselor townend katha wells
agenda item number seven changes to the
2016-17 capital program and the 2017-18
to 2020-21 capital plan once more I was
advised in accordance with council
procedural 1706 I'll call for a recorded
vote on the motion or amendments or
substantive motions I'll call again fees
on council determined Thank You chair
this report sets out progress on
delivering this year's capital program
and revisions to the capital program for
2017 18 onwards largely due to a number
of projects being deferred forecasts
capital expenditure is 1.3 million less
than originally planned details
regarding expenditure and funding
changes are set out in section 2 changes
to the capital program for future years
are set out in section 3 the major risk
attached to the program is the need to
fund a proportion of it from capital
receipts as it disposals are required
that generate sufficient receipts to
fund some of the existing program as
well as to fund a proportion of the
changes in this report if receipts are
not generated capital projects will have
to be canceled or deferred cabinet
approved this report on the seventeenth
of January since then there has been a
change in the value of slippage in this
year's program but this will be reported
in the quarter three monitoring I move
the council approves the recommendations
counter town is their second the police
record limited showings birther on Thank
You councillor Gregory
Thank You chairman this reports or
earlier versions of it between before
other committees but each time its
surface is this report they are always
slight changes to have notice this time
in 3.8 it tells us that the urgent
decision by the cabinet member on the
9th of November approved an overspend of
679 thousand pounds of the faults and
identifies at 320,000 was to come from
reserves and the balance from capital
receipts except that it didn't because
if you have a look at the the report I
sorry the members decision all it says
there is that we're increasing the
project value of 664 k2 1180 k now
chairman as you know I did try to ask
the question about where this was going
to come from at the last council meeting
and I was prevented from asking that
question only now what we find is that
the answer has been slipped into this
report in just a few words and there we
are it's another raid on the on the
actual were reserved such as we can see
now of course we've been asked to
approve a capital expenditure change
being a reduction to the capital program
of 1.3 3 million but with the addition
of three new projects this is to be
achieved as councillor Shannon said by
deferring for put it into the next
financial year and canceling one other
this decreases to balance the books
because as a result of a reduction in
the capital receipts of 1.06 million
this has grown from 800,000 which was
reported for cabinet in November so it's
jumped up quite a lot since then next
year we have a capital program being
proposed that relies on 1.78 million of
capital receipts and have to ask where
the extra capital finance will come form
because the report suggests that it will
be coming from an intended for a year
asset disposal plane which as yet it's
not prepared or we might be coming from
a possible new lease in the port but it
says there in 1.3 as yet uncertain so
there's no doubt that these new projects
are worthy if the funding was available
and who wouldn't want handrails stop
revelers falling into the harbor for
this program is dependent on capital
income
and there's no evidence to assure us
that this will be available we all know
what happens with capital asset sales we
list them then we go to consultation and
then they get delisted there's no
guarantee that the income will be
available and presumably would end up
different projects into 2018-19 yet
again to balance the books when we look
at the corporate implications of not
approving the changes in this report it
says failure to enter take this process
will impact on the council's compliance
with the treasury management code of
practice well I have to say to the
members that approving a plan without
any guarantee that the funds will be
available does exactly the same I think
we should stop increase in expenditure
until we know we have the income and I
was preparing to put forward an
amendment on this but I realize it's
almost the same for agenda item 9 as
well so I should save it until then
Thank You German thank you very much
chairman I would like to thank the
officers for including there on page 55
3.1 mark to the railings at margate
because we have been asking for this for
a very very long time and I think it's a
tragedy that some people had to be so
badly injured and somebody dies there
and I know there's reasons why this
happens but I'm very glad to see that
there and I'm glad of the officers who
didn't listen to us about this one the
reason I particularly was asking
questions was about the CCTV in November
2014 an officer produced a report with
us to say that we needed to upgrade this
in fact there was new technology
available and we're reaching the end of
its life the police were going to put
some funding towards it so we were on
standby waiting to hear more about this
money from the police to help us to do
it I think it was just over 300,000 at
that time it didn't happen this year it
didn't have the year before and now it's
into the year of 2017 2018 I emailed the
officer mr. snook to ask for has
contracts been left had way any dates
for starting how serious was it and I'm
it's only a few days but I haven't heard
back from him I just wonder if any
officer or any member
can tell us have you got any further
with contracts and if this is going to
happen and is our CCTV in a found state
the other one for me was to point to on
page 54 the swimming pool at hearts down
amazing amount of work was done in
hearthstone swimming pool in many years
ago again in Barry Cox time and Richard
Nicholson's time you know refurbishment
but one of the things that needed to be
done with an upgrading of the disabled
facilities and the lose and when I spoke
to a resident a few months ago and I was
told it was still in a bad way I don't
know if you've done anything since but
if you happened I don't know if it's
wise to remove this 30,000 pounds from
there if we still have a problem I'd be
pleased to hear you've sorted it but if
you haven't I think we need to we need
to be compliant the big ones again from
my own ward of course is the fort hotel
and that's HRA money and I should have
probably mentioned in the previous item
but I don't see it anywhere in any
report and it's still a derelict site I
keeping told progress is being made I
have to apologize to residents in my
ward all the time we allocated 900,000
from the HRA account to that building
the hope for me was that we would free
up four and three bedroom houses and put
some of our older people into lovely new
flats or looking to see in our social
housing and I don't think it's in any of
our reports tonight thank you thank you
can see John that's the wells please the
interesting comment [ __ ] probably are
some things that I I people have had
thoughts of opportunity to do i think
cancer himself made the point that he
had been raising some of these issues
and i know there was certain attempt to
answer and i think was a matter of math
for them and so you couldn't add up in
the same way and maybe it was a bad
accountancy now rather than anything
else and certainly i'm not entirely
happy with some of the programs
we inherited and what we've had to do
looks all is in order to deal with it
but it is true to say that there is a
more active and ongoing at the disposal
program there has been in this council
for some time it's not moving quite
quickly as we would have hoped well I do
know that we did actually make some
sales on Monday and that we made good
prices on those chicken sales and though
i hope that therefore as that moves
through the next few months and through
the next financial year we would see
this money actually appear and fund
those particular projects and while it
is fine to say that we shouldn't
actually go ahead and find anything
unless you can absolutely guarantee
every penny of the price it's very
difficult to absolutely guarantee every
penny of the price when you face budget
changes when begin quit coming down from
government at the end of december in
terms of our revenue budget that impacts
upon everything that we do and live with
it with just a few weeks to actually
make those calculations and make it work
so in many ways these things represent
our best possible guesses and our best
possible estimates and trying to make
sure that i spent in the best possible
way for the benefit of us limbs and that
remains our concern in our commitment
and this is the way that we see that it
moves us forward as best it can be
capital and we hope you'll feel that you
can support it in the round and in the
hole Thank You counsel Wells canton of
town and weather any other words you
want to drive yes chair first of all I'd
like to thank councillor Gregory insofar
as he admits he does now nearly
understand the Pickers which is great
move on secondly thank you the second
point was councillor Johnson on the CCTV
there we are awaiting modern technology
and making sure that the new system is
fit for purpose and up to date rather
than jumping in too quickly so please
bear with us and the final point
was on the fort road and that is going
ahead in the program at the moment thank
you my apologies and if I could only
read my own writing i would actually
reply to you that will be will get back
to you later what us thing for answer XP
I'm relieved to see that you can nearly
see the figures cutter talent thank you
very much particularly the fort hotel
thank you if we cancel campin yeah thank
you share yes I did ask this question
about this 30,000 because I initially I
thought it was for ramsgate which is
really unfair however however as I found
out it doesn't say however balance of
hearts down the response I got from one
of the officers was that no project had
been identified therefore that's why the
30,000 have been cut it's however there
needs to be compliance for disabled
facilities our town then that should be
a project the 30,000 pound could be
spent on therefore it should be
identified and put back in the budget
Thank You counsel Campbell you caught me
out there I'll already gone thank you
for that counsel of town in having
delivered a summary thank you very much
so I asked mr. house to collect the
recorded vote Thank You chairman
councillor Ashby has a Bainbridge Gaza
bayford has a braidwood casa Bryn
council Buckley Catholic Campbell
count the Keith Coleman cook Catholic
honor Catholic row Brown does akharin
counselor Dawson caso de casa della Casa
Dennis casa Dexter counselor Dixon
counselor Edwards counselor Eleanor
cancer Evans council Jeremy fairbrass
castle in fairbrass that's a falcon
counselor Fenner just a game catholic
gregory eating Gregory I apologize okay
Catholic n Gregory Gaza Grove casa hatin
counselor House Counsel Jay Jones
counselor Johnston cancer Larkins
counselor Martin just a matter face
cancer Parsons Gaza Parkington just a
Piper says a Stewart Piper's castleroy
pots counter Linda pots causa Rogers
that's a res ecchi councillor david
saunders counselor Maeve Saunders cancer
savage cancer shankh casa hasta mas
noticing count to a tailor counselor
Tyler Smith casa Tomlinson castletown
end katha wells
thank you very much remember being fast
went to gender item number eight then is
the members allowance scheme for 2017-18
I move that the recommendation is set
out in the fort be adopted with the vice
chairman please second secondes
councillor Johnson chair I spoke to
colleagues before this evenings meeting
cuz I thought I might have missed
something but in the past elected
members were invited to meet this panel
and say what accounts for yourself for
every minute of every day it's some
years now since I've ever been asked to
come to meet these people I don't know
does any group or any member get invited
to talk to them and account for the are
as we spend as counselors and whether
we're value for money thank you yes
counselors are normally attend the
quadrennial review meeting and issued
with invites for that I will ask Dover
District Council hood people who
organize it on our behalf and administer
the East Kent joint independent
rumination panel to be a bit more
proactive with advertising at the
meetings for you thank you miss yous to
members agree thank you
number nine a budget and medium term
financial strategy twenty seventeen to
twenty twenty-one once more advised in
accordance with council the seizure rule
17 dot 6 i'll call for a recorded vote
on the motion or amendments or
substantive motions councillor townlands
police thanks your chair this report
presents the budget for the general fund
housing revenue account and capital
budgets for the financial year 2017 18
the council is continuing to pay
significant cuts in government funding
over the next few years and with
substantial savings already having been
made in recent years it is becoming
increasingly difficult to identify
further savings without impacting on
services however I am pleased to
announce that the budget proposals
before you tonight present a number of
income generating proposals as well as
savings which have enabled me to propose
a balanced budget for 2017 18 with the
minimum impact on services the funding
pressures are substantial in respect of
2017-18 government funding has been
reduced primarily in respect of the
revenue support grant which has been
reduced by 1 million compared to 2016 17
and the new homes bonus which has been
similarly reduced by 1 million after
adding in inflationary pressures the
pensions revaluation and other
adjustments there is forecast to be a
gross budget gap of 2.6 million the
positive news is that there are
proposals in this report to bridge that
gap cabinet has been working with
officers for many months to develop the
proposals and many of you will have been
briefed informally on details that
specifically arrange budget briefing
sessions in addition to the normal
channels council has already approved
increases to fees and charges which will
generate an additional four hundred and
ninety thousand pounds
further income generation plans set out
in paragraph 4.2 are in train for
planning housing car parking power
generation and the workshop a new thanet
lottery is also expected to generate net
income to fund local good causes which
would otherwise be vulnerable to budget
reductions efficiencies were also to be
delivered reducing the cost of services
delivering by contractors and partners
as well as council services in light of
the substantial reduction in government
funding in 2017 18 and to enable the
council to set a realistic deliverable
budget there is assumed one-off drawdown
or reserves of 450,000 pounds this is
not prepares likely as the council's
well-documented reserves position is not
healthy to mitigate risk the 450,000
pounds we've drawn from earmarked
reserves not the general contingency
importantly the 450,000 is projected to
be repaid over the period of median turn
financial strategy replenishing reserves
to their current level as regards the
medium term financial strategy it is
referenced in section 8 and set out in
detail in annex 1 there are as ever
substantial uncertainties over the next
four years but one perennial uncertainty
has been removed in that the government
has committed to fixing funding of
revenue support grant up to including
2019 20 although this funding will be
zero by the end of the four year period
of the medium term financial strategy
the outcome of the new homes bonus
review was particularly bad for
districts including thanet as the
government seeks to reduce to redirect
funding to social care which is
delivered by the county other
uncertainties relate to business rates
localization which would change the
nature of funding of local government
there are still very few clues from
government as to how this will be
implemented and the MTF s before you
does not try to anticipate the impact of
the changes the general fund capital
program is described in sections 11 to
13 it reflects the proposed changes in
the program that are set out elsewhere
on this council agenda and the detailed
program is in annex to the housing
revenue account budget is detailed in
section 14 and the HRA capital program
is in sick section 15 to 16 this budget
presumes an increase in council tax of
four point 95 on a ban de property which
equates to 2.3 one percent council on
the twenty-third of februari will
approve the council tax for 2017 18 I
move the council approves the
recommendations Thank You councillor
talent is there a second oh please I
second mr. chairman reserve the right
Thank You councillor those capture the
Gregory I suggest you thank you thank
you German yeah interest view this
report has a number of negative
inferences relating to the council's
ability to achieve projected capital
receipt leaders referred to it comes and
sounds and refer to it and section 5 11
states that capsule receipts are
projected to be two million and yet we
know that we don't yet have a capital
asset disposal program and we're still
uncertain about the possible lease
renewals section 12.2 is where the
possibility is not achieving sufficient
disposals in to sell 2017-18 is
considered with a suggestion
insufficient disposals will result in
the need to reduce or refer the capital
program or to borrowing or so how likely
is it that will be able to achieve this
figure of 2 million probably more likely
if the 1.8 meters balance of the Royal
offense development is utilized
because it keeps stated in reports that
this same income hasn't been allocated
is to reassure the people of ramsgate
that the funds are still there when
effect 1.75 million has already been
allocated there are in this report 28
projects on the capital program now the
lowest scoring five projects require a
total of eight hundred and fifteen
thousand of capital receipts rather than
wait until the Catholics capsule income
requirement is not achieved and a report
comes back to us to defer the projects
I'd like to propose an amendment to
recommendation 1 on page 73 and that is
that members approved the draft medium
term financial strategy and it's one but
at the commencement of the lowest
scoring five capital projects at an
estimated cost of eight hundred and
fifteen thousand is deferred until
cabinet agrees that sufficient capital
receipts are available I think that
makes sense unfortunately the lowest
scoring project is margate harbour
railings absolutely though after that is
the low carbon plan rent at Harbor
around a hopeless cause the ramsgate
Harbor water supply and dream land
contract now I'm not suggesting that we
persone these or cancel these I'm just
saying let's defer them until cabinet
besides there is sufficient capital to
go forward to the fact you want this gym
yes please thank you Charlie
thank you very much
so I just read this out again the
suggestion is that members approved for
draft medium term financial strategy at
annex 1 but that the commencement of the
lowest scoring five capital projects as
an estimated cost of eight hundred and
fifteen thousand is deferred until
cabinet degrees that sufficient capital
receipts are available for avoidance of
doubt the lowest scoring projects are
number one the margate harbor railings
to low-carbon plan ramsgate harbor three
ramsgate aqua stores for ramsgate harbor
water supply and five greenland car park
enhancement do we have a second to
please Thank You Council voted
I note some counselors have already
asked to speak on the original motion
but as if anybody wish to add any
comments to this amendment okay in that
case i'm sorry mr. Willis yes thank you
very much mr. Lewis thank you thank you
Kevin it was just a bit of context
really the capital program is funded
largely by a capital receipt that
component of it which is a moveable
feast so the capsule receipts were in
the process of making disposals and the
level of capital cities going up so we
may have enough to fund the capital
program the other thing that that's
going on is the capsule program is is
changing all the time sometimes a
project has to be deferred it's not a
choice it just gets slipped by a year so
if if we're anticipating now what could
be the situation in a number of months
time it could be that one of those
lowest-scoring projects is could go
ahead and a higher scoring project
officers concluded that it's impossible
to go ahead so we would let that one
slip if council makes the decision now
to enforce that the five low scoring
projects in in anticipation of
circumstances not changing then it might
be that they might not be the right ones
it will end up we'll have another
project being slipped because it's going
to sleep anyway plus those five and
we'll end up with an overfunded capital
program councillor wells please I think
that that latter point really is the
most important one lost it would be nice
to end up with an over fund a couple of
program it's not something i can
remember happening in this council guy
we are mindful of the fact that the
program itself is one that has to be
monitored closely throughout the year
and i hope that your attention to detail
councillor Gregory will help us monitor
that very closely as the year goes on
but I do think it is important that
there may be some serious
external factor that takes something of
our highest-scoring project out of the
program in due course and if we did that
having made the decision in that
particular way I think we actually limit
the flexibility might have to actually
move those things around so I accept the
the general thrust of your concern I
don't think this is a particularly
helpful way of actually dealing with it
and I'll be delighted to welcome you
into monitoring closely how we have to
deal with it if the worst of those
happenings occurs on route Thank You
counselors counselor Gregory Thank You
chairman well it's great to know that
some you know there is every likelihood
that there will be enough money in the
in the capital program that's I can only
go on what's in the report in front of
us of course and knowing that things are
looking a lot more rosy now then in all
honesty gym and I'd be quite happy to
withdraw the amendment if you want to
listen did you get that yeah I said that
in the light of the optimistic comments
made by mr. Willis I'll be more than
happy to withdraw my amendment because
obviously it sounds like there will be
enough money to carry out the full
program thank you thank you cancel
Gregory that's in fact what i was asking
here thank you very much for that so we
return then to the substantive issue and
and I call on counselor Johnston please
thank you I'll particularly wanted to
come to item on page 89 about asbestos
removal I have written to offices but I
my attention was drawn to an issue in my
ward this week somebody who should have
a new bathroom a new kitchen and is
waiting some time for it because of
asbestos it won't happen if we're going
to wait for every property to be void
before we actually do the work we're
going to have a problem and so I just
wonder if if the cabinet member for
housing could say what is happening
that's particularly flat for the top of
Margate high street where the tenant
advised me this week that he's waiting a
long time for kitchen and bathroom my
hub contact of the head of service but
it seems to me because our husband
asbestos removed in other properties
someone needed disabled
sylheti and we had to wait for the
asbestos cost us a lot more but it is an
issue with these old blocks the other
one I would draw attention to as well it
is when our council tenants pay for
service charges they pay their council
tax which means street cleaning and weed
removal I see very little weed removal
in the front of any of the flats in my
ward and in fact the standard is quite
poor at the moment I'm sure you'd want
to know about this I'm sure it'll come
up with your tenants meetings but if
we're talking about our budgets and
capital but it is all part of it it is
in here about cleaning contracts being
renewed and being reviewed and we're
saving money but are we saving money at
a cost to our tenon thank you in some
cases that are paying twice Thank You
counsel in philosophy and I don't know
what the actual which ones are be done
in which order I do know that they're
moving as fast as they can with yes
vessel so if you'd like to send me the
details of particular tenants that you
have worries about then I will find out
what's going on in that particular
instance as far as the contracts that
have just been a new service contract
for cleaning and I think there were some
issues with it originally but I think
those are all being ironed out now but
if there are ever say if there are
problems the particular areas let me
know and I will look into it thank you
guys for therapy Thank You chair man
standing is that in view of the the drop
in recycling in the recycling rate
central government are expecting local
authorities to develop their own policy
I note that residents have put a high
priority on recycling in the
consultation on the budget and that PDC
are obviously looking for ways to
generate more income I have been trying
for several weeks months
to have information about recycling here
in infinite but still waiting for it
nonetheless I can estimate that roughly
it costs CDC around 40,000 pounds a week
to send waste to landfill sites and
obviously recycling also generates
income special paper so why is there
nothing in this financial strategy about
increasing recycling
what were you singing you wanted to
speak with no no I was just dumb point
counselor tender to the capital program
we have a vehicle replacement program
for the waste and recycling fleet which
will is some investment I'm never sure
whether I'm focused and as episode 50 /
the and that's an example of where we're
investing in the service through the
capital program which won't be apparent
from the revenue budgets that you see
before you thank you cancel brim please
Thank You chair and we are currently
undergoing a quiet or very comprehensive
review in my portfolio which is and
you're going to see changes over very
soon but that review is commonly just
about coming to an end and so we've been
scrutinizing that as the new
administration so yeah that's that oh
yeah Thank You chair as members are
aware i'm always here to help and assist
well I can and I let's start I have a
cunning plan for income generation not
for this financially I'm fortunately
button for the future ones well I think
if council to consider it's a spoof
fifteen percent increase in their preset
with a referendum yeah I understand this
then generate a response from the DCLG
yes now I caution here but when this
correspondence does take place you
should get the right email addressing
and text address otherwise it could go
lady neat and I mean cut with a code
name you could call it cold I'm sorry
Thank You cancer a camel on the ball as
usual can't thank you for that position
I would have to confess I had an equal
amount of sport in the front of mr. Paul
Carter on the same subject yesterday
cancer the Taylor Smith please thank you
very much chairman I don't think I can
really call it counselor Campbell on
that so I shall get down for the new
britty as i always do if I'm a couple of
items to mention item 7 the budget
consultation obviously I personally
think it's rather disappointing to only
have 442 responses and 399 residents I
was one and I hope all the other
counselors in this room also responded I
yeah maybe you didn't but you know it
would be nice to know if they actually
responded online only or whether it was
a mixture of letters and may be safe to
face or telephone calls and what is
being done to actually increase the
participation or engagement whichever
word you choose we can't use the
consultation very often these days we
have to use the correct words I note to
improve that because this is important I
do Jess I know but it is important and
of course to see the services rent has
the highest priority yet again household
waste and recycling has been mentioned
before which I totally agree with street
cleaning and Community Safety none of us
can argue with asses you know they are
corporate values after all and secondly
in the recommendations at number three I
would like to know if it's meant that
members agree to reduction in the grant
and minor preceptors as per section 2.15
or in fact I think it's a typing mistake
I think it's actually 2.7 on page 77 and
it would be nice to know mr. chairman of
the amount of money here that is
mentioned 117,000 four parishes how is
that actually broken down because after
all not all of our district is perished
as we all know and I would for example
mention Margate so any response could be
gratefully received thank you
you
contact at this point Thank You German
and yes it is a typographical error it
should be 2.17 ungrateful to counselors
and tell us mr. that the breakdown I can
write to the counselor on on that and
provide a breakdown of the hundred and
seventeen birthday isn't in the in the
report I can't point it to two anyway in
the report and in respect to 7.1
consultation we were a bit disappointed
it's mixed is not just online or just
telephone it's mixed and we were a bit
disappointed and we are seeking new ways
to engage or consult with residents on
the financial matters in a more general
way not just on a one-off basis but
during the year in the lead-up to the
next year's budget cuz well yes thank
you I my understanding is on I was just
checking whether mr. Issa talking is
that approximately six percent those
responses were on Pedro's forty percent
online Thank You counselor basis please
thanks chairman just two points really
the first is I think we've got a
constitutional crisis on our hands
because I think that when the amendment
was drawn by a second that should have
been asked if I agreed with it and I
didn't so I think they have to rerun
this entire device from that point
anyway no the other thing is that i
thought that i was now so old that I
would never do anything for the first
time again but I'm fine that we're going
to do that tonight I'm actually going to
vote as a member of the opposition for
the butter and then it before but Phil
tonight is the right thing to do
research for that the budget making
process has been I think open and frank
mr. Willis's workshops that he held were
very very useful this budget has been to
government's an audit it's been to over
you and scrutiny and that those meetings
the whole cried can't sorry and Gregory
is actually
I points which have been incorporated
into the budget so I feel that in some
part the budget is ours as well they
should be the council's budget i think
this one is so i'm going to vote for it
thank you thank you very much to council
baited are there any other more comments
before i go return to cancer well
counselors please thank you i wish you a
correction now i got those figures wrong
way around cancer terraces in the sixty
percent online and forty percent on
paper I apologize for that Thank You
cancer basis for your generous support
we have tried very hard to make sure the
budget process is as open and
transparent as possible and I I'm glad
that's been appreciated i'm a grateful
to your support for this particular
budget and i commend this budget to the
council Thank You Carson attorneys to
summer no I'd like to thank council
bayford once again for your support
thank you very much mr. Hauser you
please contact them call your vote Thank
You chairman councillor ash be counted
bainbridge chance of a food Gaza
braidwood that's a brim counter Buckley
got a Campbell has a Keith Coleman cook
Catholic ala casa crow Brown that
saccharine counselor Dawson councillor
de casa della Casa Dennis Gaza Dexter
casa Dixon counselor Edwards counter
Eleanor Council Evans counselor Jeremy
fairbrass castle in fairbrass casa
falken casa Fenner gaffer game council
Ian Gregory Catholic n Gregory castle
Grove cutter hatin
councillor how's cal so Jay Jones
counselor Johnston got the Larkins
casler Martin counselor matter face
councillor Parsons counselor partington
council Linda Piper council Reverend
Stewart Piper casa Roy pots counselor
Linda pots counselor Rogers cancer res
ecchi councillor david saunders
counselor maze saunders kausar savage
causa shankh casa hasta más purchasing
casa Taylor casa Taylor Smith casa
Tomlinson casa Townend casa wells
Thank You Vera tis a momentum-changing
agenda agenda item number 10 then is the
appointment of the council's external
auditor for 2018-19 and onwards one
small council of town increase XJ can't
see the current external audit contract
expires in 2017 18 once for 2016-17
accounts are audited there is a national
collective scheme that could be
commissioned external auditor that
Commission's external audit services on
behalf of participating lateral
authorities this scheme operated by the
public sector audit appointments limited
requires opting in by councils most
councils are going in and this report
recommends that 10 than it does so to
debate the main benefits of opting in to
the collective scheme or that it
provides commissioning expertise and
capacity and offers increased purchasing
power especially given that there are
very few potentials suppliers of local
local authority audit services I move
that council approves the
recommendations thank you is there a
second to please a second Thank You
councillor Ferris comment do members
agree thank you agenda item number 11
then is the proposal to change the date
of the 23rd of March 2017 meeting I'll
ask mr. house the director of corporate
governance of the monitoring officer to
explain what we're doing Thank You
chairman yes as the requirement that all
the East Kemp councils meet on the
twenty-second of March to discuss the
East Kent merger report and the council
already has a meeting on the
twenty-third at March
so I'm recommending that we move the
general at the meetings of the ordinary
meeting back from the 20 30 Mike's to
the 22nd device to do that the counter
must suspend council procedural 2.2
which says that council meetings or will
ordinarily be held on a Thursday so
there's recommendations are proposed
Thank You mr. house I move that the
recommendation as set out in the port
would be adopted with the vice chairman
please second second is to members agree
thank you very much that concludes the
business for the meeting of this council
thank you very much members